أنتوا شنو تريدون هسه،!!
تريدون أبيع العراق؟
تريدون أخون قضيتي؟
خذوني ع المشنقة أشرف لي )..
قالها صدام..
ماذا تعرضون علي؟،
هل تريدون أن أبيع بلدي،
أو أن أخون قضيتي،
هل تريدون أن أوافق وأنا أسير على ما رفضته وأنا رئيس،
كلمات كان صدام يرد بها على كل العروض التي تلقاها
لينجو من حكم الإعدام،
ويخرج في المقابل من العراق،
نعم! فالغرب ما زالوا يقدمون له العروض،
حتى آخر لحظة قبل إعدامه،
لكن جواب صدام معلوم،
أنا لم أخف من الأعدام وأنا طالب في الثانوية
ولم أخفه وأنا قائد للعراق لأكثر من عقدين؟...
فما الذي عرض على صدام ومن الذي قدم له العروض؟
هاهو دونالد رامسفيلد وزير الدفاع الأمريكي في عهد جورج بوش الابن،
يلتقي بالرئيس صدام حسين في سجنه،
ويعرض عليه جملة من الشروط من ضمنها أن لا يعود إلى الحكم
مقابل أن يكون حرا طليقا، فسأله صدام
(ما جئت به تطلبه مني الآن هو نفس ما جئت تطلبه مني عام ٨٢
عندما كنت أنت رئيس لجنة الأمن والدفاع في الكونغرس الأمريكي؟،
فقال نعم..
فقال صدام رفضت ذلك الأمر في عام ٨٢ وأنا رئيس
وها أنا أرفضه الآن وأنا أسير)
وهنا يتذكر البعض مقولة صدام الشهيرة
(إذا خانتك قيم المبادئ فتذكر قيم الرجولة)
المحامية العراقية " بشرى خليل " تقول في لقاء تلفزيوني " على شاشة " روسيا اليوم "
: اعلم إنه تم الحديث مع " صدام " على إيقاف المقاومة ،
و قبول العرض الأمريكي بالرحيل إلى " قطر " ،
إلا أنه و بسابق معرفتي ب " صدام " سيخرج من السجن إلى المشنقة فقط .
حيث أنه يرفض الاغتيال السياسي أو أن يعيش متخاذلاً .
و تابعت: في رأيي إن الهدف كان إنهاء وجود " صدام "
من على وجه الأرض ، و أن سيناريو الربيع العربي
لم يكن ليحدث في حال وجود " صدام "
و إنه كان يدافع عن وطنه و ليس عن وظيفة رئيس الجمهورية .
أما رئيس الوزراء العراقي نوري المالكي
فكان يعلم أنه قد تم عرض التنحي على صدام قبل الغزو
مقابل أن يتولى " قصي " ابنه مقاليد الحكم مكانه..
وصدام رفض التهاون كالعادة، لذلك فقد تم تسريع حكم الإعدام
من طرف المالكي حتى لا يتلقى صدام المساعدة ويهرب من السجن،،،،
صدام الذي كان خلوقا مع سجانيه مبتسما معهم،
وكان يطعم الطيور عند خروجه من الزنزانة
بما تبقى من أكله ويسقي زرع حديقة السجن،
وكان يشرب القهوة مع التدخين ليبقي ضغطه منخفضا،
لكن في المحكمة لم يكن له من خيار، وتغير القضاة ٣ مرات
بعد رفض صدام لشرعيتهم وبعد أن ألجمهم رموا الرايات البيضاء
أمام زئير الأسد في قفصه،
ومع ذلك وقف صدام شامخا صلبا في المحكمة
وهادئا يتكلم عند اللزوم،
أصدرت المحكمة حكما بإعدامه شنقا ......،
فحاول صدام تحويل الإعدام من الشنق إلى الإطلاق بالرصاص
كما يموت الجنود دفاعا عن أوطانهم فرفضت المحكمة،
وعند تنفيذ حكم الإعدام في يوم عيد الأضحى،
وفي وقت الفجر طلب صدام معطفه لكي لا يشعر بالبرد
ويظن الناس أنه خائف،
وقف مبتسما أمام حبل المشنقة قائلا
لمن حوله هذه للرجال ويقصد المشنقة، ،،،
.. صدام لم يفاوض لإطلاق سراحه وإنما ليموت كالأبطال،
ولا يليق بالبطل أن يخاف،،،
وهناك انتهت حياته لكن لم تنتهي قصته وبطولاته......